[Music]
thank you
human blood is blue
[Music]
fear I've got something to prove
no one ever needed
you don't believe me
you always see it
[Music]
feeling like California
thank you
foreign
[Music]
like
I know nothing and I'm on my way
is getting longer every day
[Music]
it's getting longer every day
we can get more
[Music]
foreign
I hope you enjoyed that flow session uh
I've done a lot of work with Gunslingers
in the past few years and I thought that
I would put together something that
included as many Gunslinger variations
as I could think of so that was fun it
was a good challenge
um wanted to do a quick shout out to
ultra boy for sponsoring this video and
giving me an excuse to go out and show
off all that Gunslinger action if you'd
like to grab a set of those orb POI LED
contact boy or boy Pro LED contact boy
that I was using in this video you can
do that by using my promo code
drexfactor with a zero instead of an O
at checkout over at ultrapoi.com that
gets you a discount on your order and it
helps out the channel so everybody wins
thanks so much to ultra POI for
sponsoring this video
and speaking of thank yous I have thank
yous to offer to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flowfests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel That
is Becca beckonen thank you so very much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission and speaking of thank yous
this video would not be possible we're
not for the awesome support of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon uh they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
think one and all of you for your very
generous supports and if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
Factor POI and signing up there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you
if you would like to check out more
videos of my flow sessions I will go
ahead and include a link to a playlist
of them down in the description as well
as up on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also if you're watching on
YouTube the YouTube algorithm thinks
that you'll like this top video here
based upon your past viewing habits so
maybe give that a look as well thank you
so much for watching please make sure to
like And subscribe be sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon
peace